en france toulouse se souvient
aujourd'hui je te l'explosion meurtrière
de l'usiné azf une catastrophe qui a
traumatisé la ville rose trente et une
personnes avaient trouvé la mort près de
2500 blessés vingt ans plus tard c'est
une fois de plus en ordre dispersé que
les hommages se sont organisés certaines
associations de victimes ont décidé de
boycotter la commémoration officielle
des manifestants se sont aussi donnés
rendez vous sur le rond point du 21
septembre pour rendre hommage aux
victimes un rassemblement à l'appel de
la cgt
rien n'est véritablement changé bien au
contraire en termes de droit du travail
en terme d'obligation des entreprises et
qu' il ne doit plus y avoir de
catastrophes industrielles comme celle
des dettes j'avais toujours entendu dire
qu'un jour aux élèves ça pétera c'est
une chose qui circulaient dans le
quartier il y avait des gens qui
travaillaient comme ça comme un intérim
l'été puis un jour un élève ça a pété et
là j'ai découvert que
l'industriel m'avait pas prévenu j'ai
découvert que les exercices de sécurité
pour la population il aurait dû en avoir
mais y en avait pas eu j'ai découvert
l'accident il ya une énorme mobilisation
dans le traumatisme de la du lendemain
de l'explosion dans le jour de
l'accident de l'explosion je me trouvais
sur le site seveso 195 route d'espagne
gt r mon travail ce genre là
et donc j'ai essentiellement été touché
au niveau de la sphère orl
donc au niveau de l'audition au niveau
de mon système nerveux
et au niveau psychologique